so thank you for coming to the talk on
machine learning in the age of
increasing data privacy consciousness it
is very relevant to the talk we just
heard so that's good there is some
continuity just give me a second while I
bring up my notes you all can now see
what I had prepared hahaha awkward
great cool so the day was May 25th and
we all made a lot of new friends I
remembered us these companies were on
the lookout for consent and the fact
that so many you decided to email you on
the same day and the fact that they're
all looking for consent meant that
something important was going on that
day a few of us probably ignore them a
lot of us probably deleted them I
because my job dictated it I decided to
look into it further and this got us
into something interesting
now the eagle-eyed among you might have
noticed that I didn't read any of them
except for one and maybe that tells you
where my interests lie so I will be
addressing three questions today why
should I care about data privacy and
this is really coming from data
practitioners perspective and I use the
term data practitioner to really mean
data scientists or data engineer a
machine learning engineer may be bi
person doing some predictive stuff so
it's a catch-all term sometimes I use it
interchangeably but that's what I really
mean so why should I care about data
privacy and if I convince you that you
should care then what are some best
practices or principles that we can talk
about and in this section I will really
draw in from my experience at Shopify
and also we hear a lot about hey if I
actually start following all these
privacy laws is really my creativity my
entrepreneurial spirit are really being
affected and in this section I will
tackle the topic of hey does this really
have to be a win-lose situation or can
it be a positive sum game so a little
bit about me
my name is Sam Tao Selah and as I was
introduced
I lead a data science team
at a company called Shopify I will get
into them a little bit later and I build
marketing recommendations for merchants
that are on our platform in order to
help them really make the best use of
their marketing dollars this is my first
conference talk so thank you for being
here and full disclosure I'm not a
lawyer so take everything I say with a
little bit of grain of salt and as we're
in the process of disclosing fully
that's not me I'm a big fan of a stock
photo site called burst and a lot of the
pictures that are used in my talk today
are from there if you like some of them
we can talk about where I got them after
the talk so why should I care about data
privacy and this is really from the
perspective of a data practitioner so
having a Terms of Service on your
website isn't that enough having a
privacy dot my company name com really
enough isn't this a lawyer thing why do
I need to care about this let me just
build my algorithms is the general
thinking around this and I'm really glad
to see that that's changing but to
answer this question I think we need to
take a step back and talk about sort of
what is the society we're really living
in and this is the age of
disintermediation and personalization
okay the largest taxi company doesn't
own any cars the largest hospitality
company doesn't own any hospitals that
was a joke
it doesn't own any hotels and the
largest retailer doesn't own any
inventory right so the middleman is
being cut away or in many cases really
being consolidated into a few large
companies and these companies really
offer service that is tailored to every
individual that is using their platform
right so is the age of disintermediation
and personalization so this means now we
have the arrival of data science right
in order to get personal you need to
build algorithms in order to
you know decide ideal pricing you use
some algorithms to figure that out
so all of this is producing a world
where really algorithms are ruling the
world right that shouldn't be news to
anyone so not only has data science
arrived but data is becoming King
algorithms are more and more being
open-source right that's not the secret
sauce anymore it's really your data and
how it's being applied that is the key
to finding value from these algorithms
and from the data that you have so more
and more data is becoming the strategic
mode this is the thing that is going to
ensure that you can keep competitors or
BAE and this is going to ensure that
you're really able to provide a service
that is valuable and unique to your own
customers and customers and consumers
are starting to take note as well this
was a recent picture from a show called
the Patriot Act that is on Netflix and
they did a show about a big retailer and
the conclusion was it's actually crazy
how much data these large companies have
right and there you know rightfully so
using that for their strategic advantage
everything I described to you sounds
like it's actually progress then what is
the problem is there something hiding in
plain sight that actually explains the
picture that I have there
so if we go back to the claim that data
is our strategic mode and that really
resulted in all sorts of data being
collected the price of storage went down
right so there's no real cost to
actually gathering something having it
in your warehouse hoping that some day
you find use for it
and in many cases the users themselves
actually were not aware of what data was
being collected how it's being used and
when they you know say I accept these
terms and services the value that they
were really giving away by giving away
their data was not really transparent
right so the customers were giving away
data let's say to connect with their
friends the company was using this data
to show them relevant ads and maybe that
exchange of value is very well
understood right but how about if who
I'm friends with was also used to swing
an election is that now what I signed up
for okay and this really becomes the
question that needs to be answered so
should my race gender or where I live
all be used potentially against me right
and all of these things are personal to
me and should my privacy be protected so
then there are laws for these right
there are laws that are protecting me
against these I mean true but these laws
some of them were actually written in
1978 right the world that existed then
and the world that exists now is vastly
different right but the good news is
legislators are taking notes they're
coming up with new proposals and they're
really concerned about data being sold
and monetized without actually the
customers so the consumer is knowing
about it they're really concerned about
data breaches and they're really really
concerned about the lack of control that
exists right and the most famous one
that was actually
in the last talk as well as GDP are the
general data protection regulation now
this went into effect on May 25th 2016
there was a two-year grace period that
was given to all the companies before
they had to implement it and now this is
serious business because it's a
regulation that means when it was passed
it immediately became law in all EU
Member States
right and that's a lot of people so this
law actually gives a clear legal
definition to what is personal data and
how it needs to be collected how it
needs to be processed and how it needs
to involve the customers in deciding
what is actually done with the data that
is collected and this can be set in a
slightly different way it's any piece of
data that can be linked to an
identifiable individual can become PII
so that means the definition is fairly
broad right and we'll get into that
later as well so this log gives
consumers a lot of Rights the right of
access or explained ability you have
determined something about me now
explain it to me that becomes a right
under this law right off rectification
so you have something about me that I
deemed to be wrong give me an
opportunity to correct it that becomes a
right right to be forgotten right to
restrict processing so okay give me you
know personalized ads but don't share my
data with people that can use it poorly
that's a right that's under this law
right to object and also data
portability right no more vendor locking
I want my data and I'm going home
give me my data so all of these rights
are provided for in this GDP our
regulation so this law actually doesn't
prevent a whole lot of things this is a
mean now you can't use machine learning
for anything all it adds is a layer of
complexity that is called consent and
how that is managed right so nothing is
banned it essentially becomes a
compliance burden
and the cost of actually the following
these laws are very expensive I don't
know how many of you know is actually 20
million dollars or 4% of your global
revenue last year whichever is higher
is serious business it could put you out
of business and it has many people that
saw this fines and said we're not gonna
be ready or we don't have the capital to
be gdpr compliant and thus we're going
to shut down our company our store our
online game etc all of these happen true
in reality and you saw that the day
after this regulation came into place
there are actually huge lawsuits that
were filed against Google and Facebook
the next day so people are serious and
this is serious business one caveat
though it has a lot of new language in
this law and many of those have yet to
be interpreted you know legally so as
the years go by I think we'll get more
and more clarity about sort of the
framework in which we can function so
you can think that this is happening in
the EU why does it really matter to me
and it's not just the EU Canada where
I'm coming from recently had a lock how
much California proposes this year and a
new one
federally is being proposed by something
Wyden as well so as I was doing research
for this I realized that actually in the
United States their individual states
dictate a lot of these and right now
there are 48 states that have laws
governing data privacy and regulation
right so in order to be compliant it's
very difficult so this is an attempt to
actually put it all at one level and
enforce it and globally or federally so
then if we go back to this definition of
personally identifiable information and
if any resemblance of this definition
has actually used elsewhere then we're
we need to be serious about this because
a recent study showed 87 percent of the
US population can be identified just
based on three data points that's the
date of birth
that's the gender and also the zip code
so that means if you have all these
three data points sitting in desparate
tables that's a problem right because
all three can be combined and now we can
identify majority of the u.s. population
so hopefully I've convinced you enough
that there are now legal reasons why we
should care
ethical reason Society legal reasons
that we should care as data
practitioners because this is affecting
the world in which we operate and we
need to take you know practical steps in
order to account for it right I just
want to reiterate all of these laws
don't prevent us from doing machine
learning don't prevent us from analyzing
things this adds a compliance burden so
that we respect the rights of the
consumers that have been given these
rights legally so I will pull out a few
principles not techniques but principles
really that I have found to be useful in
my work and I will lean on some of the
things that I've learned at my company
as well so I think as we go into these
principles it might be worthwhile to set
the background off the company in
particular so this company is called
Shopify not to be confused with Spotify
it is a leading cloud-based platform
that allows people to set up stores
online or pop-ups offline and really
takes away the burden of running their
store from a back office perspective so
one of the things that we provide as a
data team is actually insight so that
people can run their stores to look
better so an example of a store is Red
Bull all of the things they sell online
is actually powered by Shopify another
example is the New York Stock Exchange
and they're about 600,000
other such stores on our platform so
shop fire in the industry is actually
known as a ruby and Glo shop but all of
the data team is actually powered by
Python we rely very heavily on PI spark
and also more and more now on the
tensorflow stack as well so as you're
designing your pipelines I think it's
now becoming more and more critical that
we design them with correction and
transparency in mind right so as data
practitioners it's not enough for us to
just deliver a prediction but we need to
get more and more involved and how these
predictions are being surfaced right so
having build pipelines with correction
in mind is actually a right that people
get under gdpr
and I'll go through an example of a home
card so these numbers are not true so no
need to pay attention to that but this
is an example of a home card a home card
is a card that shows up in home-home is
our name for the administer stores this
is where if they got an order they would
go there to take a look at where they
got their order from this is where they
would create discount codes this is
where they will look at analytics to
understand you know who is coming into
their store how much money they're
making etc etc so really this is a place
for us to as a data team have influence
on the merchants running and operating
their store so this is one such home
cart it says hey your conversion rate is
similar to other stores in apparel and
accessories so the fact that they're in
the apparel and accessories industry
there's actually a machine running
algorithm that looked at everything that
they sell and it said okay we predict
that you're in the accessory apparel and
accessories industry but if it's not
their industry we should actually give
them a chance to correct it and that's
what we do here where they can click on
hey this actually is beautiful
information but that's not my industry
right is not useful to me and we allow
them to correct it in the same view we
give them other options and these are
actually the second and third highest
making predictions for the same shop and
if not they're able to put in what their
industry is and from the drop-down menu
that is pre-populated and when they
update their industry we actually give
them a small message saying hey we've
updated your industry to show you more
relevant content and this is where the
transparency part comes in so we have
now tied the loop to what we predicted
your industry to be giving you an option
to correct it but also because of the
fact that you took the time to do this
we're telling you hey we'll use this to
provide more value show you more
relevant content right and this is a
great example of actually baking in not
only correction but working with UX
folks to bring in their transparency
that hey this is a prediction we're
willing to correct it and also this is
the value that you're providing for you
principal to take the time to explain
your predictions so one of the rights
under G DPR is the right of explain
ability right and more and more as our
algorithms are becoming black boxes even
as practitioners we sometimes have a
hard time figuring out what is actually
going on in the hood so when a merchant
is looking for help or trying to
understand why is it that you want me to
do this we should be ready to provide
them with a explanation now if it's free
right if you're saying okay here's an ad
maybe it's not as relevant but if we're
asking them to spend money based on our
recommendations then we have to be a
little bit more serious so what we can
do here is in baked into our prediction
we can also send what our major features
are right and I'll show you an example
where this plays up beautifully so
Shopify has a chatbot that merchants can
employ and one of the ways we deliver
this recommendation is through a chat
bot and this is a sample example says
hey James we've had more than X number
visitors to our store in the lacs X days
let's start a retargeting campaign to
remind these visitors that our products
about our products and bring them back
to purchase right in order to reach our
visiting visitor audience I recommend a
budget of X for X amount of days and
retargeting campaign on a XYZ and
platform can I show you a preview of
this campaign so this is you know anyone
that's done marketing can already pick
out what the major features are that the
algorithm was acting on right and by
really surfacing that right to our
merchants they have a very clear
understanding of why we are recommending
them the things that we are recommending
them and when we're asking them to spend
money that's really important not only
it is important it actually
ups our acceptance rate by a magnitude
so here we're really being transparent
and we're taking the time to explain our
predictions right and this builds trust
and we'll get into that a little bit
later so a third example that I have is
touching on the principle that I like to
call the golden rule so do what your
consumers accept we'll be done with
their data right if I am you know
accepting that you will connect me with
my friends and in exchange show me a few
ads I am accepting of that right I'm not
unreasonable that's the cost of free but
if you're saying that I'm you're going
to use the same data now to politically
change how an election goes through then
I have a problem so if we follow this
golden rule I think we'll you know
bypass a lot of issues this as an
example is part of the orders page so if
our merchant gets an order this is the
page they generally go to here they can
see you know what was the cost of the
order you have a little bit of you know
conversion summary and also you have a
section called fraud analysis and this
is an example of we using you know data
from our merchants or their customers
in order to come up with an algorithm
that detects fraud
so fraud is very unique under gdpr
because it has a special provision that
allows us to use PII data in order to
build algorithms that detect fraud and
here I think it's a great example to go
through that actually touches on the
previous two principles that I mentioned
as well so simple fraud analysis right
but we also have a section in there that
says view full analysis so fraud
analysis low that would be our
prediction right but we go a step
further to say hey you can actually dig
in deeper and now we have all these
indicators for you right and those
indicators are blocked them out because
they contain some information that I
can't share these are for that
particular order what their IP address
is right how far away is their
registered credit card from where
they're shipping it all of these any you
know fraud analysis algorithm would take
into account now we give them in detail
hey these are all the things that come
together in coming up with this
prediction so this is explained ability
transparency and also using the
information that is provided to us in a
way that the merchant expects it right
and we go off the step further we say
hey you want to learn more and they can
click on that and get more information
so you might think here that it's a lot
of you know you X things but behind all
of these are our pipelines that and our
models that we build and that we put
into production so our sort of
responsibility should not end with just
a prediction right that's the bare
minimum that we can do and providing
more information that the UX people can
use to actually build a story really
while satisfying you know all of the
rights that they get under gdpr is the
way to go in this case and also when we
talk about
the last principal it's also important
that we use some of the new techniques
that are coming on board right designing
pipelines with privacy in mind things
like collecting only what you need data
minimization as soon as it hits your
control anonymizing it so that
everything downstream doesn't have to be
you know PII aware and using techniques
like differential privacy to really
minimize your exposure in case of the
data breach among other things and one
of the ways this is nicely achieved is
through progressive consent right so
don't ask for consent and don't collect
interrelation if the consumer has not
come to a point where they're actually
using that aspect of your product so in
the example that I gave off the chat bot
if a consumer is not using our chat
solution and is not you know accepting
marketing recommendations then don't
bother collecting PII information
relating to that right when they do when
we have their consent we can go ahead
and do that and offer them a fairly
solid solution so I think I've shared
with you that things are required
legally I've also given you a few
principles how we can sort of take all
of these things and put it into our
products but this is something that a
lot of people have trouble with so here
is big government really putting the
clamps on innovation right but does
privacy really have to be a zero-sum
game and the hypothesis that I'm
pursuing is no so here's a quote by
doctor and Kevorkian she was the chief
privacy officer of the province of
Ontario where the City of Toronto is
located from where I travel yesterday
and she actually makes a claim that we
have now tools that can serve as
technologies of freedom and it's not the
dystopian view or the
view of zero sum or win-loss models
simply put it doesn't have to be a
win-loss it can be a win-win and this is
something that I hope to show a few
examples of so in when we are talking
about principles we lightly touched on
the element of trust okay if we're
transparent if we allow our pipelines to
be corrected by the users if we are
really harping on the fact that we want
to provide value here's where you can
learn more here's how we're using our
data your data this really increases
trust in our product right and if Trust
is there then when we do ask for
additional consent and more likely to be
provided so as we increase trust as
we're transparent about the value that
we're providing this benefits the
customer because you know they can use
our product knowing that we are being
honest with them and also are conscious
about their privacy but also from a
company's perspective this really
becomes the differentiating factor in a
very crowded environment by showing
we're a company that believes in your
privacy and is using your data in order
to service you and we have no ulterior
agenda that you do not know about also
our previous talk touched on you know
algorithmic biases and measuring them a
lot of these biases actually originated
from personally identifiable information
their proxies that exist for sure but
raised gender and all of these PII
information actually in in the cases
that were presented in the previous talk
do a lot more harm than good and you're
actively trying to remove them from your
predictions so by actually removing them
from your taining data in the beginning
you actually have better training data
and you you know spend less time
actually tuning your model to be more
fair and when we take a look at the
correction mechanism or the way to
actually have feedback back into your
model you're actually crowdsourcing
training data
right training data is one of the
hardest things to get good quality
training data while you're building
algorithms and what you're saying is hey
now consumers if you trust us to use
this properly and we have a corrective
mechanism baked into our pipelines we
can collect better training data from
you and as a result will give you better
predictions and better value so all of
these things are actually both ways they
benefit the company and the benefit the
consumers as well and that to me is an
example of a win-win also this goes into
gdpr a little bit I think many of us are
very familiar with this we freaked out
every time we got an email from from him
and under gdpr there actually strict
laws that say how you need to react when
you are aware of a data breach and the
last PII information that are stored in
our data warehouses let me tell you the
better write our recent emails that I
got was about LinkedIn another that my
cousin got was about Equifax all of
these are major companies that probably
host information about majority of the
people in this room and the fact that we
don't you know from the BNA choose to
follow principles of data minimization
and we don't collect information we
don't need it's less headaches later on
right and that of course benefit both
the consumers and the company as well
and storage costs are minimum but it's
still a lot of dollars right and if it's
data that you don't need that you're
processing every day and that's a lot of
dollars storage and processing it
definitely helps to cut those down when
not needed and save a little bit of
money there so in conclusion I posed
three questions why do I need to care as
a practitioner of data science I think
they're strong legal reasons to care the
second question was what are some
principles that I can follow
please follow the golden rule and can
data privacy be a positive sum game and
I propose to you that this can be a
win-win so thanks a lot for your time
and that's all I have for today we have
a few more and more as consent overload
and that's a real problem and the way
we've sort of found ways around that is
through progressive consent so you give
us consent for the part of the product
that you want to use and until then that
is all hidden away from you right it's
not these broad-based consent that you
give us access to everything at all
times but it's really based on the part
of the product that you want to use
mapping that back to the consent that we
need and at that time really exposing
that to the consumer and asking them to
accept and when it's done in context
then the overload portion is negated
quite a bit right instead of when you're
signing up you're signing up to all
these forums and at that point you're
not really sure do I really need this
what is it being used for but in context
it really hopes but it is a huge problem
I think the UX folks are keenly aware of
that I think they're working on some
interesting things from that
you
[Applause]